hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes my name is Matt Simon I'm here
to recap the most ravishing language and
ideas for the last week of Wired first
up today we're talking about a wired
science gallery of amazing photos of
colliding galaxies so some of these had
interesting names such as the cosmic owl
and the Tinker Bell triplet and they got
these names because well one of them
looks like an owl and the other one
looks like Tinker Bell if Tinker Bell
were made at a raging plasma instead of
pixie dust this phenomenon of applying
meaning to a meaningless object is
called pareidolia it's when you see a
cloud in the shape of a dog or even more
interesting a dog in the shape of a
cloud and there's the always-popular
face of Jesus and a burnt piece of toast
which is discovered almost exclusively
by people who both love Jesus and toast
as opposed to people who love l ron
hubbard and pancakes appropriately
enough carl sagan theorized about
pareidolia he proposed that we see human
faces where there are none because we're
hardwired to recognize a human mug as
often as possible from evolutionary
perspective this allows us to tell
friend from foe so when you look up in
the night sky and see the man the moon
you might subconsciously think he's
either friendly and delicious because
he's made of cheese or he's a big shiny
high-faluting up next the glorious world
of kitsch a raw file disk that a profile
on a woman who creates these
fantastically kitschy dystopian
postcards but what is kitsch it's a
category of art via film paintings music
that is so tasteless and oftentimes so
overly sentimental that a word was made
up for it in 19th century Germany so
here's the thing with kitsch and I hate
saying that there are two types of
people in this world because the wild
generalization but there are two types
of people in this world those who would
buy Thomas Kincaid painting and those
who would rather buy a drug-addled
Wolverine to adorn
home so the pleasure in kitch derives
from recognizing it as such and for
those who don't recognize it as kitch
enjoy it in their own sincere way they
just haven't spending more of their time
watching QVC people will of course
collect catch ironically valuing it for
its tackiness there's no better place to
be on earth as a collector of kitsch and
in a totalitarian society because
provocative art is banned the Kitsch
which is safe and unassuming proliferate
Kim jong-il was particularly fond of the
stuff some even say that when they look
at a map of North Korea they see a
tinkerbell figuring longing to escape
the confines of a tyrannical state
either that or look suspiciously like
three colliding galaxies
you